now in Tanzania playing with 49
passengers on board has crash landed in
Lake Victoria the Precision Air flight
from Dar es Salaam was attempting to
land at bukoba airport which is in the
northwest of Tanzania 23 passengers have
been rescued so far
let's get more on this we're joined on
the line from the port city of Dar es
Salaam by the journalist faraji saeedi
thank you for joining us for Raji tell
us a bit more about what you think
happened
yes there is a plane crash in bukoba the
plane number PW
49494 it's a Precision air which was
carrying 49 passengers which crashed
while landed in bukoba airport at around
2 30 East African time this morning
according to police commander of bukoba
who has issued the preliminary report so
far they are saying that it's due to
weather bad weather and fog because it's
raining around that area
uh so far according to the report uh 23
uh passengers have been rescued and
other more are still con the rescue
process is still continue in in the area
and uh according to the according to the
report it says the
plane crashed while it was trying to
land at bukoba airport it's a it's about
100 meters from the airstrips so the
plane is currently inside Lake Victoria
you say 49 passengers on board 23
rescued so still quite a lot of people
unaccounted for uh explain to us uh your
understanding of uh where the plane is
you say it's in Lake Victoria how
difficult would the conditions be when
carrying out the rescue efforts
so far according to the to the police
Commander Regional commander of bukoba
Mr William uh he's he's saying that the
efforts are continued and uh so far
according to the picture which we have
seen from the from the from the uh from
the local Medias which has been uh
circulated in the media they're showing
that uh it's it's not far from the land
it's about 100 meters so they so far uh
the the the rescue efforts are continued
what the commander say is that uh
everything still is under control so
they are they are they are they are sure
of rescuing more people uh so far and uh
they promise to give the report very
soon as they still continue with the
process can you tell us anything about
the airline itself Precision air
well it's a it's it's one of the of the
of the plane which is uh uh which is
more favorable in in Tanzania and it has
been working in Tanzania for so many
years and uh so far it has no any no uh
uh history of of of of of of any crash
uh in in a recent years
um so it's it's something which uh that
they're saying it might be accidental
accidental because of the weather but uh
so far so good it has no history of of
of of bad history of of crashed I really
appreciate your time uh farage East idea
journalist speaking to us there from Dar
es Salaam about a plane a Precision air
plane that has crashed into Lake
Victoria so far 23 people rescued